- I'm an open book.
- What do you mean
- I am very trusting that.
That's why I've been fucked over so much.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right, Todd.
Todd, where are you from?
- I'm from San Diego.
[Interviewer] And you
currently live in San Diego?
- I currently live from San Diego.
I grew up in Salinas,
California Monterey County.
That's where I was raised.
And I continued up in
San Diego because my wife
got pregnant with triplets.
We lost two and we have,
our oldest son is 27.
He is blind and has cerebral palsy.
And that's how I ended up in San Diego.
Cause he's in the hospital for so long.
And I have another son it's in long beach.
That's why I was down in this area.
He's going to college via be a doctor.
So, and that's kinda how
I ended up over here.
This area, I ended up in long beach,
and I was mugged there by a female.
And do you want me to
elaborate more on that?
- [Interviewer] You can go
a little bit of that, sure.
- Okay, well I met this
girl through these guys
and I had some stuff I was trying to sell
and she seemed pretty
connected and I was very tired.
She said, well, I can get a
room for a couple of hours.
I said, sure.
I said, I need some sleep.
Then wasn't even trying
to do anything with her.
And she offered me a drink.
I took the drink within 10 minutes.
I was not feeling well.
And I was out and everything
else was like a dream.
And I woke up in the hospital,
very irritated and very
didn't know what was going on.
Could barely talk and
walk and they finally
I don't know why they, they kicked me out.
Cause I guess I was being a problem.
I'm not quite sure it was like a dream.
And I realized I wasn't in San Diego.
I was in Long Beach and it
hit me that I was robbed,
my truck was gone.
My tools, everything was gone.
And I did get my truck back,
but everything was stripped.
- [Interviewer] So they drug you.
- She drugged me, yeah.
While GHB or something,
she poured it in the beer.
And her name was, oh, she went by Nice.
(laughing)
And so I was stuck at my son's in
Long Beach for a couple days.
Cause I didn't have my truck.
And I called my brother up, who lives
in LA and asked him to come down,
if we could drive around and
I found her and cops came.
They didn't do anything about it.
But anyways, so then I came
down here and I met Savannah.
And she approached me
about having sex and stuff.
And I said, okay.
She took me up to her
room and she was actually
very hospitable and she was cool.
She didn't burn me.
She didn't do anything.
Everything went well.
Then I met TT and that didn't go so well.
She just, she just worked me
and worked me and worked me.
My fault cause I allowed it.
And her boyfriend who goes by
Frost, he ended up burning me
for a $500 Home Depot Card.
So I was done with them.
Then I met a girl named Alicia and she
approached me for sex and this and that.
And she fucking, I was
so tired cause I was up
she got me some crack.
I was up for awhile and I
fell asleep and she fuckin
just robbed me there again, I got robbed.
And the thing is, all these people
I've gotten them.
Most of my bottom tent candy bought a tent
cause they needed it.
I got him stuff and just been worked.
That was another one that, Candy.
It's just been one after another.
One of them set me up and had
a guy in there and beat me
and again, tempted to take everything.
But at that point I
didn't have anything left.
But my my addiction is what
kind of brought me here.
You know what I mean?
Looking for dope.
- [Interviewer] What is your drug?
- It was cocaine as what I started with.
And then I ended up in the
'90s started smoking crack.
- [Interviewer] And crack is a much more
intense version of cocaine.
- Intense.
- Yes. It's more addictive.
You just want more and more and more.
You just never get enough of it.
And so that is my drug of choice now.
And I've been through number of programs,
and in and out and clean for many years.
And I'm very successful
when I'm not using.
It's just, I'm some somewhat
functional when I use too.
But it just takes me into the wrong places
and this and that.
Like I said, I just been stuck here
for the last three weeks.
Trying to get back up and
I just have been taken
advantage of by everybody.
And then I met him, Grue and
he, he told me about you.
But so, if that happens,
damn, I'm back to San Diego.
- [Interviewer] So, your life
in San Diego, you have a job.
- Yeah, I do, I-
- [Interviewer] You don't need
to tell me too many details
- Well I'm doing a big job right now.
I'm doing a complete,
a room about this size.
I'm doing a massage
parlor, putting plumbing,
electrical, all that in construction.
- [Interviewer] So you do construction.
- I do construction.
I was a owner of Absolute
Construction for 10 years.
- [Interviewer] And you're still working.
- I'm still working.
- [Interviewer ] Yes, you got-
- I've been stuck for
three weeks and out of,
- [Interviewer ] You're a
little out of control right now.
- I'm out of control.
Yeah, I'm on a good one.
- [Interviewer] You're on a bender.
- But I finally reached out.
See what I do is when I go on a good one,
I lose all communication with everybody.
I don't talk, call anybody,
and I haven't to anybody in three weeks.
Finally I picked up the phone
to the guy he's waiting for permits.
We're at the stage that
he needs the permits
and he he's been calling me
and reaching out and I
just I've been so down.
And then just beat up that,
I just haven't talked to anyone.
But I did pick up the phone
yesterday and he just says
just get back, just come
back, just come back.
He wants me to finish the job, you know?
I told him I would, let me see
if I can get some money
to get there and get back.
- [Interviewer] But are you still married?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] You are.
- [Interviewer] Do you do this kind
of stuff in San Diego as well?
- Yeah, I do.
Yeah, absolutely, I do.
I was doing quite a bit
over there and I don't know.
Like I said the reason I came over here
was cause of my son lives in Long Beach,
and then I kinda worked my way over here.
In San Diego, yes I'm also
using there, but I'm working.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Right, but
certainly your wife must know
something's going on.
- Oh yeah, for years.
The thing is it's just
like the people I work for.
They know who I am when I'm not using.
I'm very productive.
They just can't believe who I am when I,
because I'm a very productive person.
I've always had great jobs.
I used to be a plant manager
for Fresh Express, running 200 people.
I'm a very productive person
but then I get on this I start using
and then I just, you know, disappear.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it
affects all kinds of people.
It affects everybody in my life my son-
- [Interviewer] No, but
I'm saying the people
that are down here on
Skid Row looked like,
oh they're just a bunch
of homeless drug addicts.
But the people like
yourself who are successful
and have lives and successful kids.
- I don't look at anybody here down
and out drug addicts like
that I take everybody as,
I mean everybody is just like me.
I'm a drug addict.
I could be here too.
I mean, I am here.
I'm just stuck for three weeks.
But you know some things
I don't understand.
I mean, there's always
some kind of avenue.
I mean I'm doing it down in here
for three weeks looking at this
and there's always some kind
of means there's help out there.
There's this and that.
And a lot of them don't even care
about that or do anything about that.
They just keep doing the
stuck in the same thing.
Kind of like I've been
stuck for three weeks,
but I will, I will snap out of it.
Like I say, I finally picked up the phone
I'll be going back to
work and this and that.
And usually this has been a good run.
I'm probably, I do very well in programs.
You know what I mean?
I programmed very good and drug programs.
- [Interviewer] You've gotten clean.
- [Todd] And I get clean, absolutely.
Last I was clean for two years.
The last time this has
been my longest one.
I was using because I
was making good money.
I was using, this is
the most I've ever used.
Between an eight ball and a
quarter ounce of crack a day.
That's doing it nonstop.
And this stuff wasn't
even affecting me anymore.
But when I didn't use it,
I would go into panic.
You know what I mean?
And I would get very
moody and this and that
but this has been my longest run.
Then ending up over here,
people can't believe
where I'm at right now.
Even my twin brother over here,
he says, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
I said, well, I've been stuck
and he's not talking to me.
Otherwise he would have helped me.
But anyways.
it's just, it's been a real experience.
It's time to turn it down
and help myself again.
- [Interviewer] So, you have your car?
- I got my car back, yes.
- [Interviewer] And
what's keeping you from
just going down to San Diego today?
- Today, money.
Money is the only thing.
- [Interviewer] I'll
help you out with that.
- Okay then-
- [Interviewer] If you'll be out here
on the freeway in 10 minutes.
- No.
If you're not in the
freeway and 10 minutes
I don't wanna give you any money.
- No, no, I'm going to my
son's first in Long Beach.
I told him I'd seen him before.
- [Interviewer] Don't go
see Nice and Long Beach.
- Yeah, huh?
- [Interviewer] Don't go see Nice.
(laughing)
- I couldn't believe
that Nice of all names.
- [Interviewer] So you've had all kinds
of crazy stories like this from your past.
- Oh yeah, oh yeah, even down in,
I've been even down in San Diego.
When I finally found out
where, because like I said,
my handicapped son took us down here.
There's a Imperial Street
down in San Diego, man.
I went down there and people
are just on the corner
kind of like this and
they're just selling drugs.
And I ended up buying it and I just went
on a roll down there
and I've been guns held
to my head and just all kinds of stuff.
My addiction has taken
me some crazy places.
I've been very lucky, but like I said,
people in my life really nobody's ran out
on me because they know who I am.
And they know what I'm about.
- You seem like a good guy.
- I'll help anybody.
- You have this drug addiction.
- I'll trust everybody.
And that was my problem down here.
I trusted everybody until they burned me.
Then I went to next brit.
Everybody told me everybody
down here was taken.
And I understand, I
understand that they're
in survival mode and I understand
there's people down here
the mental illnesses,
you know what I mean?
And, and I take that in consideration.
Just to go ahead and have me,
I just don't understand it.
People that I was actually helping that
rob me and had me beat
up and this and that.
I just, I don't know, it's really made
me take another look at things.
There's some really
ruthless people down here.
You know what I mean?
I mean, I hate saying
that because I don't know.
I don't know, but I just thought
I had enough and it's just,
I just need to get out of here.
- [Interviewer] Yes, but what is it that
typically triggers you into using again,
or going out on a bender like this?
- You know, it's because
I am a kind of guy.
I take everything on, I overwhelm myself.
I'll get a couple few jobs going,
and then I'm making good money
and I'm helping everybody out.
And that's what I, I
don't think about the fu-
I live now.
I just, everybody I help try
to helping my family as much as I can.
My brother was locked up.
I take too much on and
I just get overwhelmed
and the stuff just shuts everything out.
It blocks everything out
for me, that's what it does.
For years, I've been asking,
why do I use, why do I use?
Cause why?
I'm very hyper.
And it just, it shuts me down.
I don't think about anything
else except take another hit.
That's that's why I do it.
You know what I mean?
I think I just overwhelmed myself
and I just say fuck it.
You know what I mean?
Being the addict I am,
I think I already know.
I already know once I take that hit,
it's on a roll, you know what I mean?
There's no stopping.
I lose all power.
Soon as I take that hit, I lose all power.
And I'm still productive,
but I procrastinate.
I'm not dependable
but there's certain
people that I work for.
They know that.
And I'm very honest.
My son knows everything about me.
He knows everything about me.
I'm very open with him.
Everybody does, knows everything about me.
I don't lie about it.
Because they know who I am
and what I'm about when I'm not using.
And even when I'm using I do a lot,
you know what I mean?
I do a lot to help them.
Don't, don't get me wrong.
They're very upset at me.
And they they're tired of me,
them getting hurt by my addiction.
Cause I am hurting them.
I just disappear, they're worried.
They don't know what's going
on and it's not fair to them.
So as my mom would say, just leave.
If you're gonna do all that, just leave.
Cause you're just making
everybody miserable.
That was the one thing
that mentioning my mom
who's was my, everything.
She passed away of lung
cancer and it was just
what three years of fighting it.
It just destroyed me.
It just devastated me.
I couldn't believe
- [Interviewer] Has it
has been worse since Then?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Has your
addiction been worse since then?
- Yes, yes.
- Yeah, I can honestly say yes.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about childhood.
You had both your parents?
- My childhood, my dad was German,
and he was in my life maybe
a couple of years old.
So I really didn't need
bouncing in and out of my life.
He was really my dad, wasn't my dad.
He tried to be my friend.
I would grew up with a stepdad.
His name was Orville
and he was an alcoholic
but he did everything with us.
Took us, fishing, took us,
you know, he did off-roading.
He just did everything with us.
And he was a good man,
except the alcoholism.
He's got real bitter with my mom.
You know, he used to beat
up my mom and this and that.
My mom was the type of
person that always worked
and just try to hold the whole world
on her shoulders, take care of everybody.
And she was just a great person
and we had everything we needed
and everything else we lived well.
And there was really no drastic things.
In my childhood, that was devastating.
My stepdad did approach me at one time,
tried to have sex with me, but I wrote it
off to get, he was drunk,
he only did it once.
- [Interviewer] And nothing happened?
- Nothing happened.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Huh?
Yeah, I was kind of devastated by that
because he meant a lot to me
because he was like my dad more
than my dad was and yeah.
It did bother me.
It did bother me, but nothing happened.
I just said, oh no no, what are you doing?
And he, and he didn't do anything.
So as far as my childhood, I
had a pretty good childhood.
You know what I mean?
With school, graduated
school and did all that.
And then I got a job with
FreshCo at a young age.
And then ended up being
a plant manager there.
That's when I started doing coke.
But I was functional,
I was very functional.
I was definitely an addict,
but I was very functional.
Until they asked me to go
to land in Georgia and
open a plant for them.
And I went to land in Georgia
and that's when I got hooked on the crack.
And first it didn't grab me.
I didn't like it, cause
I was never satisfied
in smoking, I wanted more and more.
So I went back to snorting
and then I did it some more
and it just grabbed me.
It grabbed me.
So I told my boss, Bob Warnock that,
hey, cause you told me
come up here a year.
Open this plant, it's been a year.
I need to go back home.
So I go back home.
Now, mind you, everybody.
I knew everybody I knew
in the '80s, early '90s,
snorted coke, everybody did coke.
That's when coke was big.
And when I went back home,
they'll be was snorting
anybody, everybody was smoking.
I couldn't, I'm like, wow.
So I started smoking again.
So then I moved again
and it just had follow me wherever I went.
So anyways, like I
said, I got clean again.
And I met this girl and I got
her pregnant with triplets.
And I ended up in San Diego
cause that's where my son was
in the hospital for a year.
And I got in the construction.
I took a leave from the produce company,
and I got into construction
and I took off.
Met a lot of different
people and I did well.
I stayed clean for a long time.
And then like I said, I ran
into Imperial Street, downtown San Diego.
It was haunting me that I
knew where to get it now.
And I went down there one day
and got it and went on another run.
So, but this one has been my longest.
And then the uses has been great.
Just I've got can't believe,
all the money I've been
making has just been going
to this and not helping
people, I need to help.
And they're like, where
all your money going?
Where all your money going?
Even the guy I'm doing
the massage polar for.,
He's been handing me
thousands and thousands.
And I got four grand left on that.
It's all gone.
Because of this, and I'm gonna tell you.
And most of these tricks, I
didn't even have sex with.
I just got took, you know what I mean?
And, this is the first time I really
been doing the prostitute thing.
I've really never gotten
into that or anything else.
But down here I was
trying to get the dope,
and this and that.
They drew me in, me wanting
to have sex and didn't get high.
It hasn't been a good experience,
has been not been a good experience.
And maybe that's good for me.
Maybe that's gonna turn me around
cause I'm definitely getting
the hell out of here.
- [Interview] Hopefully this video,
and being able to see it and know that
it's exposed out there in the real world
might just help you take ownership,
take responsibility for the situation
that you get yourself into often.
- Yeah, well I didn't think about that
but I'm hoping a few
people don't see it, but.
We can talk about-
- That's okay.
It's okay.
No, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
- [Interviewer] What I found
is sometimes admitting it,
exposing it helps-
- They own it.
you get past it, to hide
the hide it keeps it alive.
- Exactly, exactly, exactly.
Yeah, so that's not a problem.
It's not a problem, it's good.
- Sometimes-
I'm feeling a little bit nervous, but it's
it's all right, it's a good thing, it is.
I'm not worried about it.
- [Interviewer] Sometimes
confession is powerful.
- [Todd] Yeah, yeah.
So they'll be glad to hear that I've been
taken advantage of and then
put through the ringer.
- [Interviewer] Well, I'm
gonna send you South from here.
If you're not on the
freeway in five minutes
I'm gonna get this done.
All right.
Well, thank you so much for talking to me.
Okay.
- [Interviewer] Okay.